اهلا بكم ومرحبا المشاهدين الكرام فيها
نسال عن دور المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في
ليبيا في ملاحقه مجرمين الحرب ومرتكبي
الجرائم ضد الانسانيه ومدى تداخل اختصاصات
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مع القضاء
الليبي وذلك على هامشي هذه الزياره زياره
مدعي عام المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه كريم
خان الى ليبيا تقديمه من طرابلس تحديدا في
سابقه من نوعها احاطته امام مجلس الامن
الدولي حول الوضع في ليبيا مشاهدينا
الكرام في الاستوديو الاستاذ عبد المجيد
مرايا ريال محامي ومدير قسم الشرق الاوسط
في شمال افريقيا اليوم منظمه اف دي
الدوليه استاذ اهلا بك مرحبا شكرا جزيلا
على تربيه الدعوه شكرا مرحبا مرحبا كل
الترحيب
بضيفي في الجانب المقابل من طرابلس
الدكتور ضوء المنصوري المحامي رئيس لجنه
السلطه القضائيه والمحكمه الدستوريه في
هيئه صيغه الدستور اهلا بكم ومرحبا شكرا
جزيلا لك على تلبيه هذه الدعوه واسف عن
الخلل الذي اخر التقني الذي اخر التحاقك
بنا استاذ مرحبا
مرحبا بك وبضيفك الكريم مرحبا دكتور منصور
مرحبا كل ترحيب باذننا بكما ما تعليقكما
اولا على زياره المدعي العام للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه كريم خان الى ليبيا
الاولى من نوعها لمدعي الجنائيه الدوليه
الى ليبيا منذ 10 سنوات افريقيا
جرائم كلها مشتركه وتدخل في اطار المواد
ابتداء من ماده همم السادسه الماده
السابعه والماده الثامنه والثامنه مكرر ان
لم اذا كان هناك عدوان بحسب بحسب العالم
ثم وجود السيد المدعي العام
10 سنوات
الفصل السابع من ميثاق الامم المتحده على
اعتبار ان هناك احاله لماذا لان ليبيا
بالفعل ليست دوله تعرف في نظام روما
فبالتالي جاءت في اطار هذا الفصل السابع
الامم المتحده بحاله من مجلس
الدوليه هي مستقله عن كل الياء اماميه طيب
اطرح سؤال عن على ضيف ايضا في الجانب
المقابل من ترابسي ده الاول زياره عمل
يقوم بها مده عن عام للجنائيه الدوليه منذ
عقد محادثات ما عدد كبير من المسؤولين
الليبي بمن فيهم رئيس المجلس الرئاسي
وزيرته العدل المدعيه العسكري انتقل حتى
الى الشرق تفقد مواقع مقابر جماعيه قبل
احاطته هذا اليوم امام مجلس الامن الدولي
ما تعليقك انت الدكتور ضوء المنصوري
المحامي ورئيس همم لجنه السلطه القضيه
والمحكمه الدستوريه في هيئه صياغه الدستور
على هذه الزياره مرحبا من جديد
شكرا لك على هذا السؤال المفصلي لكنني همم
انتهزوا هذه الثانيحه لان احيي القضاء
الليبي الذي اخذ همم يشق طريقه نحو تحقيق
العداله وان يباشر التحقيقات في الجرائم
التي اهملتها المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
رغم المصاعب وفقد قضاه وفقده خلال نيابه
وفقد موظفين ومراكز من مراكز
المحاكم وبالتالي لا بد لي في هذه الثانيه
بالرحمه على من فقدوه لتحقيق العداله في
بلدي الذي يضجه بالجرائم التي بدات منذ
2011 واما زياره همم المدعي العام للمحكمه
الدوليه همم جاءت في الوقت الضائع لان
المحكمه الدوليه لن تحرك ساكن منذ الفين
2011 رغم اتفاق الكامل مع همم الضيف
الكريم لان المحكمه الجنيه الدوليه تستمد
اا يعني ولايتها من قرارين مجلس الامن
1970 اضاءه 71
و193 الا ان المحكمه الجنيه الدوليه رغم
الشكاوي ورغم التحقيقات لم تحرك ساكرا عن
عن اي جريمه وقعت في ليبيا منذ 2011 همم
هناك شكاوي من برجفانا وحي لاربعه همم
يعني موجوده لدى المحكمه الجنيه الدوليه
على اثر حرب فجر ليبيا هناك شكاوي من همم
بن وليد على اثر القرار رقم سبعه بجياح
هناك شكاوي من ضحايا ماجر همم يعني همم في
سنه
ثمانيه 2011 هناك شكاوي من الضحايا همم
الكثيرين يعني المتدربين في خفر السواحل
في ظليط همم هناك همم مدبحه همم يعني غور
هذه الجرائم التي لا زالت تتكلم الى اليوم
لم تحرك شعره من المحكمه الجديده الدوليه
ولم تحرك فيها ساكنا وبالتالي همم بدا
القضاء الليبي يشق طريقه ويبدا التحقيقات
في هذه القضيه رغم العقبات التي يواجهها
كل ذلك
لسد التغيرات التي اهملتها المحكمه جنيا
الدوليه وما زياره المدعي العام نحكي
مجانيه
الا لدرف الدموع على المقابر التي تجاوز
ال 300 و60 مقبره دكتور الهويه همم هناك
مقابله همم
سوري
اليك حتى تسترسل فيما ذهبت اليه ولكنني ما
فهمته منك ان الجنائيه الدوليه في ليبيا
فاشلت فشلا بريا ما رايك في ذلك هل هذا
الامر صحيح فعلا من كان كذلك ما رده همم
اشكاله وانه وانا
ممطر
تقريبا لكن فقط اكمل
لتوضيح فقط بان محكمه هي الدوليه عندما
تمارس هذه الولايه في في في ليبيا هي
تمارس في اطار التكامل بمعنى هي لا تقصي
القضاء الليبي هذا ما ببدا نصت عليه
ديباجت نظام روما نصت عليه في الماده
الخامسه
تستكمل ما ابتدئه القضاء الليبي من
اجراءات نعم تاخر السيد المدعي العام او
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه تاخرت تعاطي مع
مجموعه جرائم على اعتبار حاله الصراع التي
كانت متواجده في ليبيا ولكن كذلك تاخرت
الحكومه الليبيه فاطمه جرائم لان الحكومه
الليبيه اذا اردت بالفعل ان تفعل المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه لماذا لم تلتحق نظام
روما لماذا بقيت مكشوفه الايدي وانا اتذكر
وكنت طرفا في ذلك انه طلب منا اعداد
استشاره قانونيه في مساله الانضمام الى
محكمه الجنايه الدوليه وانه كان مسؤول
قانوني في احدى الحكومه السابقه الليبيه
يعني استشر عدد من خبراء القانون الدولي
هنا في اوروبا
ورقه في هذا الباب لكن قطع التواصل بعد
ذلك لان الانضمام الى محكمه الدوليه كان
سيحل هذا النقاش الانضمام الى محكمه
الدوليه كان سيحسم هذا الامر وسيئجل
التحقيق هذا اخرى هناك من دخل سليم حتى
اذا كان الانضمام معقد قلنا تقدمنا
باستشاره في هذا الباب وقلنا التوقيع
والدكتور المنصوري اكيد مطلع هذا الامر
على الفقره الثالثه من ماده 12 من نظام
روما ان القضاء الليبي يتنازل عن سيادته
عن اختصاصاته للقضاء الدولي عندما يتع
الامر لان مساله تم اغتيال القضاه تم
تصفيه القضاه بمعنى انه القضاء ضعف بهذا
الامر ليس ضعفا لعدم استطاعته ولكن ضعفا
لان قدراته البشريه تم استهدافها فبالتالي
كان من ذكاء الحكومه الليبيه ان توقع ولو
لم توقع على نظام روما لانه هناك حسابات
سياسيه
لكن كان عليها بالاولى ان توقع فقط على
الماده فقره الثالثه من الماده 12 كما هو
منصور عليه في نظام روما المؤسس من
المحكمه الجنائيه طيب الدكتور اول منصور
اذا ما قررنا بفشل الجنائيه الدوليه في
ليبيا فان فشلها من فشل القضاء الليبي
يقول ضيف هنا في الاستوديو
وهذا الفشل يقول اخرون فشل جنائيه الدوليه
تتحمل سلطات الليبيه ايضا مسؤوليتها عن
لماذا له عدم تعاونها مع جنائيه الدوليه
في ملفات عديده منها ملفات تسليم
المطلوبين وحتى انه في مرحله ما في تقرير
رفع لمجلس الامن الدولي تم الحديث عن همم
اشكال عدم التعاون هذا وبالنظر ايضا لي
الوضع غير المستقر في ليبيا والذي حال دون
اجراء تحقيقات ميدانيه وجمع الادله
الجنائيه
والشهادات البعض يقول ان هذا التحميل ربما
على الجنائيه الدوليه ليس في محله وان
القضاء الليبي ايضا لم يقم بما يجب ان
يقوم به كيف ترد على ذلك وعلى ضيف ايضا
حقيقه ان ضيفك العزيز همم يعني اراد ان
يدخلنا في متاهات قانونيه محسوم فيها
الجدل وهو ان الاختصاص للمحكمه الجنيه
الدوليه همم ليبيا ليست من الدول التي
وقعت على اتفاق روما ولكن الاختصاص الذي
عقد المحكمه الجنيه الدوليه هو بموجب
قرارات مجلس الامن
19193 وبالتالي لا ما دعاه للقول بان عدم
توقيع ليبيا على اتفاق روما سيكون وعائقا
امام حرائق المحكمه الجنيه الدوليه في
الساحل ليبيه لان يكفي للمحكمه الجنيه
الدوليه لو كان صادقه ولو كانت همم قادره
على القيام بمهامها ان تحقق فقط في
التقارير التي وردت الى مجلس الامن في
التقرير التي وردت الى المحكمه جنائيه
الدوليه في الشكاوي التي يعني لا زالت
تقبع في اضابير المحكمه جنائيه الدوليه
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لم تحرك ساكنه
في اي في قضيه سواء كان كبيره او صغيره
الا الان همم وبالتالي همم مبدا التكافل
هو لا يمنع المحكمه الجنيه الدوليه من
التحقيق في الجرائم ضد الانسانيه وجرائم
الحرب التي كانت تحت عين و و و ووزن
المحكمه جريمه الدوليه من خلال تقرير
مبعتيها ولجان حقوق الانسان التابعه
للمحكمه الجنيه الدوليه التي قدمت عده
تقارير نصف سنويه للمحكمه الجنيه الدوليه
تتناول فيها الجرائم ويجب على المحكمه
الجنيه دولي ان تباشر دورها بالتحقيق في
الجرائم ضد الانسانيه وجرائم الحرم دكتور
استطيع
السلطات الليبيه هل تعاونت بشكل كاف مع
الجنائيه الدوليه هذا ما يعاد احيانا على
هذا التكامل الذي يجب ان يكون ما بين همم
اتصلت المحكمه ال- مع الدوليه محكمه
جنايات والقضاء الليبي هل كان هناك تعاون
هل تم تتعاون اصلا
بالتاكيد لان المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
كانت لديها مطالبات باشخاص يا اما يعني
تتم محاكمتهم امام القضاء الليبي او هناك
اشخاص همم فارقوا الحياه في دول اخرى همم
يعني مغادرتها بليبيا او اشخاص متهمين في
قضايا تمت ابانا النظام السابق وبالتالي
فان الجرائم اللي ترتكبت في في ماجر وفي
همم يعني المركز التدريب في ظليطن وفي
ورشانه وان واحد يضرب لم تفتح فيها
المحكمه الجنيه الدوليه اي تحقيق في في
همم غرغور في مركز الهجره غير الشرعيه في
تجاره هذه الوقايه هي وقايه اعمل موسى
وتضمن ناسها تحقيقات الخبراء
الدوليه الا ان المحكمه مجانيه الدوليه
احتفظت بها ولم تحرك فيها ساكنه خاصه كما
وردني مجلس الامن همم الدوله اليوم لا لا
افاده توحاطه سيد كريم خان او بعد هذه
الافاده دعى ليبيا الى التعاون الكامل مع
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه هل تمت فعلا هذا
التعاون اطرح عليك السؤال وانوه الى ما
ذهب اليه ايضا المدعى العسكري في طرابلس
الذي قال لمدعي المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
القضاء الليبي هو المختص بمحاكمه همم
الليبيين
حتى دليل على عدم الرغبه في التعامل عن
انشقاق الحاصل وانكسار الحاصل همم عفوا
دكتور
الانقسام الحاصل داخل ليبيا هو ربما كان
سبب في هذا في عدم التعاون بدايه
انقسام السياسي طبعا الانقسام السياسي
حكومه هنا وحكومه
همم السياسيه
تؤثر على كل المؤسسات الدوله
صوت القضائيه السلطه القضائيه تفقد كل
امكانياتها الاعتبار انه نفس نقطتين
سياسييتين في البلد فبالتالي كل سلطات
تريد ان تفرض امرا معينه هذا مما افقد
يعني همم الاجرائيه تجاه التعامل مع محكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه محكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
طالبت بتسليم عدد من المطلوبين على راسهم
سيبقى سيف القذافي ولم يسلم اليها الى حده
سيف الدين سيف الاسلام القذافي الذي كان
السيد المدعي العام كان رئيس للدفاع عنه
بالمناسبه همم
فقط
الامين العام السيد المدعي العام كريم خان
السيد كريم خان للاسف الشديد وادم هذا
لمسنا ويعلم الدكتور المنصوري اكيد بهذا
الامر على الاعتبار انه متخصص كذلك في
القانون على ان اجراءات تحقيق داخل محكمه
الجنائيه جد مؤقتا ولا قدام المرور
الخامس من فبراير 2011 هذا قرار سعينا
اليه من
عندما تقدمنا باول شكايه فيما يخص قضيه
الفلسطينيه من 2009 لم نستصدر اي قرار الى
حدود 2021 صادر عن الغرفه التمهيديه لكن
سيد كريم خان الى حدود الساعه لم يتخذ اي
اجراء في همم في القضيه في هذا القرار
فبالتالي الامر التحقيق وامر المؤقت امر
فيه همم حسابات سياسيه هناك دغو الدوليه
بكل بكل تاكيد هناك دول ضغطه ليس لها
مصلحه مش تحرك محكمه الدوليه همم وصول
مبعوث الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع
تواجد السيد المدعي العام محكمه الدوله
ليس وصولا سليما على اعتبار ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عائق امام عمل محكمه
التجاريه الدوليه وترفع من التدخل المحكمه
الدوليه ذلك هو دائما تروح دوليه لكي
الطريقه على محكمه الدوليه
همم
شيرين ابو عقله عندما تم تشكيل لجنه
التحقيق دوليه من اجل اجهاض التحقيق في
همم
الرئاسي سيد نور لاند سفير الولايات
المتحده
في ترافن تحدث ايضا عن السيد عبد الله
باكيلي المبعوث
الامميكي الى ليبيا همم تحديدا اعود لايك
اليك ضيفي الدكتور ضوء المنصوري حتى
تتفاعل مع الاستاذ عبد المجيد همم مراري
همم المدعي العسكري كما تبات ايضا يقول
لمحكمه يقول ان المحكمه للمحكمه الجنائيه
همم ان القضاء الليبي هو الوحيد المختص
كيف يرى في هذا انه ثم عدم رغبه في
التعاون والعله ابرز دليل على ذلك هو دعوه
مجلس الامن الدولي هذا اليوم بعد افاده
كريم خان لليبيا للتعاون لمكافحه الاسلام
من العقاب وتوفير المسائله والمساهمه في
السلام همم ايضا يعني حقيقه القضاء الوطني
الليبي بالنسبه لسياده ليبيا هذا امر منه
ولكن كثيرون يقولون ان القضاء همم الليبي
ااا لم يقم بما يجب حتى هذه اللحظه ربما
يذهب حتى البعض يقول انه حال دون ااا
محاسبه الكثيرين تستر ايضا على البعض
ويبقى القضاء ضعيفا ورهين التجاذبت
السياسيه وحتى المجموعات المسلحه دكتور
تفضل
اولا المغاره الاولى التي اداها ضيفك
العزيز المتعلقه بدور القضاء الليبي وانه
يعاني من الانقسام وهذا دليل على عدم
الاطلاع على دور القضاء في ليبيا الذي
يمثلهن معاني النائب العام الذي يبسط
سلطاته على كافه التراب الليبي سواء كان
في الشرقي او في الغرب واذا لاحظت حتى في
نشرات الاخبار قيامه بحبس العديد من
المتهمين ههه في المنطقه الشرقيه في
البيضه وفي طبرب وفي بنغازي وفي سيره وفي
طرابلس هذه اولا ثانيا همم ان همم الدور
الذي تقوم به المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
كان دورا قاصرا بدليل ان المحكمه الجنيه
الدوليه لن تقوم بدورها المناطق بها في
الجرائم الموجوده في اليها بموجب
القرانيين الذين هما ولعل الحرب على
طرابلس فيها اربعه كانت بحضور الامين
العام للمحكمه
الامم المتحده ههه كان في
والعمم المتحده ودراعها القضائيه لم تحرك
في قضيه الكليه العسكريه في قضيه المقابر
الجماعيه في ترهونه همم في همم في الهجره
غير الشرعيه في تجوره في جرائم الحرب التي
ارتكبت في ورشانه وفي الوحل اربعه وفي بين
وليد هذه الجرائم واضحه للعيان وكان يتعين
على المحكمه الجنيه الدوليه ان تباشر
سلطاتها والتحقيقات فيها حتى تصل فيها الى
النتائج حتى لو سلمنا جدلا ان القضاء
الليبي لم يباشر فيها لان القضاء اللي هو
قضاء يعني اذا باشره في هذه القضايا ينحسر
اختصاص المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اما اذا
لم يباشر فيها القضاء الليبي مهامه في سن
عقده الاختصاص للمحكمه الجنيه الدوليه
19 33 الا ان اا يعني خطبه رئيس المحكمه
الدوليه اليوم امام الاسلامي لا تخرج عن
كونها بكاء على اللبن المسكوب دون ان يقدم
اي شيء او اي دليل او اي واقعه تدل على ان
المحكمه الجنيه الدوليه قد اوفت بدورها
المقوله اليها بموجب القارات دكتور اليها
ثقته ويقول لقد جمعنا سيد كريم خان اليوم
كثير من الادله بفضل الصور والشعود
والتسجيلات في لا هاي وتونس ومناطق همم
اخرى يقول ايضا همم وفقه دائما هذه
الاحاطه انه تم تقديم همم ملفات سريه
للقضاه المستقلين بالمحكمه الدوليه للبت
فيها واصدار مذكرات توقيف بشان المجرمين
بمعنى انه ثم تقدم في عمل الجنائيه
الدوليه في هذه المرحله اضيف لان وجود سيد
كريم خان في ليبيا في هذه الايام بالذات
جاء همم بدعوه من همم السيد باتيلي همم
دعوه من بعثه الدعم في ليبيا ربما هذا
يؤشر على مرحله همم جديده في ليبيا خاصه
همم تعيين خلي المبعوثه الامم الجديد
تعاقب على ما ذهب اليه ضيفي لو سمحت سيد
مراري وهل تعتبر ان باختصارا شديد ان
الجنائيه الدوليه بعودتها اليوم همم بعد
10 سنوات الى ليبيا بهذه الاحاطه انطلاقا
من ليبيا في سابقه من نوعها ايضا ربما
تماهد لمرحله جديده في ملاحقه مجرمين
الحرب ومنتهيكي همم
الحقوق الانسانيه طبعا لان عمل السيد
المدعي العام هو عمل المحكمه جنائيه
وتغلبوا عليه الشق الفني اكثر منه تحقيق
لا زال لم يدخل بعد في التحقيق هو الاعمال
التي يقوم بها هي اعمال فنيه جمع هذه
الجلوس مع الضحايا والاستماع اليههم يعني
تسهيل امراه اجراءات مع الدوله المعنيه
وغيرها بعد ذلك يبدا التحقيق هذا امر انا
اتسال
اتسائل مع ضيفي سريعا اين كان النائب
العام الليبي مع هذه الجرائم لماذا لم
يحرك ساكنا النائب العام لماذا لم يوثق
الجرائم حتى تكون مستند قال محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه ربما اختم معك بهذا
السؤال باختصار شديد سيفوي المنصور في اقل
من 30 همم الثانيه هل قام القضاء الليبي
بما يجب ان يقوم به باختصار شديد وهل هي
مرحله جديده ربما
للجنائيه الدوليه في ليبيا من خلال هذه
العوده عوده كريم خالد
اولا يعني القضاء الليبي لم يقصر اطلاقا
في التحقيقات
وفيما يتعلق بالتقارير
والسماع لاقوال الشهود والادله كلها
موجوده في تقارير الخبراء التي سلمت الى
المحكمه الجنيه الدوليه وتعني اقول لك بان
شكوى وارتفاعانا الواحد منه وليد عندهم
ثمان سنوات امام المحكمه الدوليه لن تحرك
فيها ساكنه رغم ان نفتح تحقيقات قد اجري
هو الادله قد قدمت تحقيقات في جرائم ماجر
وفي همم وفي همم كلها قدم فيها يعني
يتضمنتها تقارير بعت الامم المتحده وخبراء
المحكمه الجنايات الدوليه لكن المحكمه
الجنيه الدوليه لم تبت في اي ملف من هذه
الملفات اشكر نحن سنكت
ونخلصنا المحكمه مجانيه الدوليه باننا
حققت في ملف واحد فقط نحن نفتخر بقضاءنا
تدعوا ان يتعافى اكثر لكي يحل همم المحكمه
الدوليه كل الشكر كل الشكر التي لا تخرج
عن كونها عصا غليظه تستخدمها الدول كلها
شكرا كلها شكر السيد عبد المجيد المراري
المحامي لمدير القسم الشرق الاوسط في شمال
افريقيا الدوليه على سلبيات هذه دعوه كل
شك جزيلا لك هذا المطرب الدكتور هو
المنصوري المحامي ورئيس لجنه السلطه
القضيه والمحكمه الدستوريه في هيئه صياغه
الدستور كنتم معنا في فقره وجها لوجه